so now what we're going to do is look at
some of the interventions that do exist
for MSM and gay men and we're going to
give you quick overviews and then some
highlights from some programs that are
doing the work so our first one up is an
intervention called many men many voices
for short we call it 3 mV it's a group
level intervention specifically for gay
men of color so what it is is it's a
seven session group level interventions
of people meeting groups it targets the
individuals to change their own behavior
and it's facilitated actually by a pier
in small groups of six to 12 individuals
the main target population is black MSM
who may or may not identify as gay
sessions are highly experiential meaning
there are a lot of group activities a
lot of times for them to do practice
skills practice group discussions and
role plays for all of us who love those
roll please and there is theory and
evidence behind this it's adapted from a
behavioral self-management an assertion
skills intervention that is actually now
called partners in prevention it the the
original research findings were that it
significantly reduced the frequency of
anal intercourse specifically that's
what was measured among participants so
they reported much less anal intercourse
to have it after having gone through
three mb and it significantly increased
condom use among the participants all
right so now to share with you their
experience implementing many men many
voices I'd like to please welcome Nadia
cabana and Juan Pablo gunam from Project
Hope in Massachusetts
good afternoon everyone when I started
this okay I'm a little nervous because
it's the first time that we're going to
talk to a big group out of our state and
but we were glad that we're here we're
glad that we're here with you to share
our experience ok so I'm Nadia the
vector of the amigo amigo program and my
name is one gorilla I'll risk health
educator ok and our program is called
the amigo amigo that means a friend to
friend and we were founded by the
Massachusetts Department of Public
Health ok where we work we work in
Project Hope and he say nonprofit agency
that is being in the lean a limited to
sit for 40 years and it's been serving a
he's been doing HIV prevention for the
last 15 years and this program is the
many many voices he's been there for
since 2002 will be there for years doing
a widow n ok what we do we do community
outreach risk assessments psupero
referrals to HIV STDs and hepatitis
screenings it when I say super referrals
is we actually bring the clients to the
clinics to have what they want to have
done and we do that because most of them
are lit afraid to go maybe because the
language barrier or a cultural barrier
so because you already engage with us in
in our program they trust us more than
the new people that are going to be
meeting so that's why we do a actually
just go with them and sit over there way
also on and you
their outreach worker we don't mind I
don't mind the time we tell them at
different times so because for us the
most important thing is for them when
they're ready because sometimes they can
decide that at seven o'clock at night
you know what i mean so when they're
ready we'll do it for them we worked
even though we were 40 hours we get paid
for 40 hours but we do this 24-7 so I'm
glad to do I been doing this for 15
years so you came we work in the North
Shore area of Massachusetts our offices
in the lean area but we go to different
cities aight to do the outreach and our
target population is the MSM latinos
okay and you're going to talk a little
more about the population but i also
want to say that every day we have
newcomers from different spanish country
so they knew it to the information
because they don't have an information
back in in their countries and when we
went against them in these they don't
know what we're talking about sometimes
we do groups a and we mention where is
HIV and nobody answers and if they
answered they give you the wrong answer
so I think this is a an education that
cannot stop so even though we supposed
to do the curriculum to MSM we also do
workshops in different locations we just
call the place a second we go to do a
workshop because the way we let them
know what we do so they can come to us
when they're ready okay
promised our IDs choosing the right team
to be able to accomplish what we need to
accomplish we need to hire the right
stuff to work in this program and we
look for people who really light the
work that they do and love what they do
and enjoy what they do and also they're
very friendly but they also keep the
boundaries with the clients or the
participants of the program and also the
day the team as a team that will share
everything that's going on in the
program so let's say a 1 a second he
cannot go to the bar tonight and Carlos
this invocation somebody needs to go out
there to do the average then I'll go so
that's how a team works we never stopped
doing outreach supervision meetings will
do weekly supervision meetings where we
talk about our challenges in the program
and how to overcome the challenges I we
also talked about the success of the
program communication communication is
very important communication with
Department of Public Health a manager
seen our agency the stuff in our agency
our team communication communication
with all the agencies in the area and
the most important one the communication
with the clients we need them to trust
what we do because sometimes they gossip
we speak the same language or they may
say well we don't I don't trust them
because I already know one already know
Carlos so I'd want to go there so they
come to me and then I'm like the person
who engage them to go to do the guys or
to come to the group's networking we
like networking what we do is we call
different agencies and we tell them we
want to go and visit them we want to
present our program in their staff
meeting so we'll usually do that and we
introduce yourself and we also
to know who they are their names so when
we refer people to them because we not
only refer people to HIV and SDI's or
hepatitis C screening people also come
with all the issues domestic violence
immigration issues so we want to know
who I we send in these people to we
wanna see faces I would wanna know names
of providers so I can call them and say
I'm sending a client to you I want to
make sure that he goes over there when
his domestic violence or immigration
related so sometimes you invited to go
and do workshops to their staff also
trainings is very important that the
staff is well trained so a we go to
trainings a that is mandatory by dph but
we also request to go to all the
trainings related to what we do and we
had the freedom to go because we had the
support of our agency ok why did we
choose this intervention back on the l
is to dial 2000 there was no many heavy
or debited shoe from this intervention
Scott three and be like you guys here it
was choosing to target black and Latino
Hispanic msn from the North Shore area
there are high risk for HIV and STD by
that time 3mb was only the one available
for those population and specially
specific for black a missing and still
we don't have anything available for
Latino msn Latino specific
how do we recruit people for this
intervention through the battle rich
about the batter reaches the most
successful place to flying a messing
game n bisexual and it's very important
how you're going to approach the people
with our keeping the wrong idea because
they might think that you are poaching
the person because you want to engage
within sexually so you got to make sure
and be careful are you going to approach
the people especially the young crowd
our cruising area or public sex and by
roaming this is a great place to recruit
bisexual men as usually they don't go to
the bar because everybody knows everyone
in the community they don't want their
wife to know that they going to those
places without her it's real rich for
this intervention particularly this
really she hasn't being as good as the
cruising in bar area but the sweater
rich has been very successful for
substance abuse program in substance
abuse prevention and they programmed
recruitment events their recruitment
events we have three series every year
3mb and before we start any cereal with
that we have a recruitment events we can
have a cookout we can have a nice dinner
if it's winter depends on the weather
and what we do we promote the activity
at the club that we go win by people win
by like the former participants so and
that's how we gather people for the
intervention media campaign we have for
TV shows every year when we promote
different stuff we talked about the
program we talk about the agency and
this is a way to broadcast the
programming bring people to the program
okay recruitment events are very
important because when we do them we we
bring the list of people to sign and we
give out a ruffles small gift we put a
big table and then we we we agree with
the manager of the bar then we put our
cards everywhere we bring food and we
usually have like 300 people that night
and we we bring counseling and testing
the same night what we were our
challenge and how we overcome language
can be a barrier especially when we have
Latinos people that were born here and
so that I Spanish is not very flowing as
mine the length of the three and B
program it's like seven weeks it's
really hard to keep and retain the
clientele what we have done we do it in
four weeks we come by section two and
three and three and three four and five
in one day each retention or
participation in audit for us to keep
the clientele coming to the program we
have to do like we often warm a gift
cards we offer like movie passes and
different type armed incentive we also
it's a little hard to have people
getting test for HIV and STD what we do
we invite agency to our program to work
groups so they offer the counseling and
testing we don't allow rapid tests just
in case somebody came out positive in
case somebody comes out positive the
person who is testing will contact the
client before keep everybody's the
result cultural competence even though
we work with Latino there is a lot of
Latino from the Caribbean from South
America Central America that they have
different comes that depends on what
we're talking about so we create a
different ground rules for the specific
challenge respect everybody's opinions
and beliefs also says we have monthly
workshop beside the 3m intervention so
we too
monthly workshop we have like 10
different topics photo done we offer
counseling and testing and this way we
can keep the client connecting in in
case they need another services defied a
beside prevention education individual
level intervention in case somebody
doesn't feel comfortable talking about
their sexual behavior sexual practice
they all we can come towards one-on-one
they usually go to an area which is
always available by ability for
participants are what we do in order to
have a better self in the group's we do
the group's on Sundays in evening which
is not the best time for us but it's the
time they actually have worked for the
program setting for the intervention we
don't do the intervention in the office
we go to people's home participate
housing we make him feel like a family
environment versus I class clustering
let's say